150 Democrat congressmen just voted
against deporting illegal aliens
convicted of
DUIs we are not talking about so-called
victimless crimes here as end wokeness
pointed out in just one case an illegal
alien named Jose menjivar with three DUI
convictions killed a 46-year-old woman
and her teenage son last month during
his third DUI incident and was released
without jail 4 days before or the crash
we are talking about real crimes with
real consequences in the real world if
the federal government enforced our
nation's most basic laws those Americans
would still be alive but they don't
enforce those laws they don't even hold
the illegal aliens responsible for the
other major crimes they commit while
they are here this is the perfect
encapsulation of America last
policymaking it's almost a pathology our
elected officials can't do enough for
foreigners even foreign criminals even
especially dangerous foreign criminals
and even more astounding they can't seem
to do much of anything for actual
Americans I'm Michael nlls this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show the
Congressional sex tape producer is not
being prosecuted by the federal
government stop the presses surprise of
the year we'll get to that story in just
a moment first though speaking of the
government prioritizing illegal aliens
over American citizens a Boston man has
gone viral after the city of Boston
Austin turned a park in a predominantly
black neighborhood into housing for
illegal aliens and this local resident
did not take very kindly to
it no equal to live here and I've been
here my I can yell cuz I can yell cuz I
can
yell and I'm angry that's why I hear you
I do hear you so why can't I get in the
building you can't get in right now no
one why where's the mirror
at y'all
this all about money it's a money
grab give a about the mother that was
born and raised here y'all raised the so
high can't afford to live here but yall
going to breach some other mother here
that is that up
it doesn't make no sense none none I'm
homeless I work a fulltime job 40
hours and get PID to live here how the
y'all going to bring somebody else
here don't make no sense
none totally agree it don't make no
effing sense absolutely the guy has
every right to be upset about that this
is someone who lives in America he works
he pays his taxes presumably and he
doesn't get to use his Public Services
because those are all being diverted
to illegal aliens from all Americans
it'd be one thing if if services and
institutions were only being diverted
from the awful terrible rich white
people or something then
probably everyone would just move along
but it's not it's from all Americans the
white people the black people the
wealthy people the poor people it's all
being diverted to illegal aliens when it
is convenient by the city officials why
is that why are foreigners being
prioritized in front of everyone in the
country I think this ties into the
decolonization rhetoric that we've been
hearing in recent months and years I I
think this ties into the the notion that
we don't really have any right to be
here the United States we're terribly
privileged everyone across all
demographics of every class we're
terribly privileged this is stolen land
it's like all of those little email sign
offs from the really woke people at the
universities the email sign offs that
say this is to acknowledge that we're on
the land of the hakah hookah hiiki
people and we don't have any right to be
here and if we don't have any right to
have National borders and anyone who
wants to come in and take our property
you absolutely should we're the worst
people in the world may aula may aula
may Moxy Mula and that this is how the
elites think it's the elites who are
putting those kinds of land
acknowledgements and self- flagellations
into their email signatures and ordinary
Americans are saying hey what is going
on this doesn't make any sense at all
and you can hear from the frustration in
his voice he says I'm working a
full-time job I'm doing everything I and
I can't even go to the park now speaking
of working a full-time job there is a
young woman who has gone viral for
making a little Tik Tock video saying
that she works a lot and she doesn't
have enough time and money to really
enjoy anything in her life outside of
work and conservatives are attacking her
and saying she's got to pull herself up
by her bootstraps and stiff up her lip
and all the rest of it but that's not
exactly my take on what she is saying
why is it
that I have to work 40 hours a week just
so I can have a place to live 40 hours a
week makes me $2,000 a month and my rent
is
1660 so I work 40 hours a week so I can
have a two-bedroom apartment and an
extra $300 a month like doesn't cover my
phone internet food you know so not only
do I not have any extra money but just
working makes me so
exhausted that I don't have time
either like I get off work at
5:30 come home and I'm just so
tired I'm so tired that
like anything that I need to do out
outside of work I then just push off to
like the weekend and I'm like I'm just
too tired to do this after work I'll
wait until Saturday so then I end up
with so much to do on the weekend that
ends up having to be split into two days
so I have to do stuff on both Saturday
and
Sunday so then I don't get a day off I
don't get a day to relax I don't get to
decompress so it is really like working
7 days a week
constantly
and I I don't want to do that anymore
right like I don't care how poor and
miserable I would have to be but I
literally can't have a place to live
without this you know
like I don't know what to do I'm not I'm
not made for this I don't have the money
time or energy to enjoy my life outside
of work and I don't know what to do
about it anymore you know I'm so
tired I know the conservatives are
making fun of her because they're saying
a listen here snowflake you know quit
your belly aching 40 hours that's not so
hard when I was a kid I used to walk
uphill both ways in the snow and I'd
work 400 hours a week and I never once
grumbled about it you it's no like but
that's not really my take on it I
totally sympathize with her I empathize
with her you know I remember when I was
younger and uh wasn't quite sure where
my career is going and hadn't quite
settled down into my personal life and
that was before we hit this this period
of massive inflation where people can't
afford anything when my wife goes to the
grocery store the eggs cost like $50
each at this point you know and they're
college educated organic pasture raised
you know properly pedigreed eggs but
still all all the groceries are like
that and the rents have gone through the
roof and what this woman is saying is I
I have trouble affording my rent I have
trouble affording my groceries I I'm
working 40 hours a week at a job that is
not satisfying to me and then I got to
do my chores and errands on the weekends
but I don't have anyone with whom to
split the bills and I don't have anyone
to take care of some of the chores and I
I'm suffering from a crisis not just of
money and not just of work but a crisis
of meaning that's what she's really
saying that's what that last line at the
end there is is I wasn't made for this
and that's true what what she's talking
about is living in a a world long after
industrialization long after the
breakdown of Civic Society a world long
after the breakdown of community where
she feels isolated and she's living
alone and she's carrying that burden
herself and and the jobs have become so
specialized and seemingly meaningless
that she doesn't see any point in them
at all doesn't really see the fruits of
her effort and she gets to the end of it
and she says I don't even have Leisure
and I'm not sure frankly I think what's
implied by our present state of society
is I don't even know what I would do if
I did have leisure time and I I don't
feel that I was made for this and I
think she's totally right we we were not
made for this we're made to be part of a
community we're made to have a sense of
our purpose we're made to start families
and have children and we're made to uh
not just be
automatons but I don't even know what
this woman's particular job is
but work increasingly over the last 150
years has turned human beings into cogs
and a machine and that's a problem it's
a problem especially when the the other
aspects of life that give you meaning
religion family community leisure
activities all go away and so you're
just left say what the hell am I even
doing I totally totally sympathize we
have to restore some kind of balance we
have to restore balance to Nature so why
I would strongly recommend you check out
balance of nature right now go to
balance of nature.com promo code nolles
balance of nature fruits and veggies are
the most convenient way to get whole
food ingredients every day balance of
nature uses an advanced cold vacuum
process that encapsulates fruits and
vegetables into Whole Food supplements
without sacrificing their natural
antioxidants the capsules are completely
void of additives fillers extracts
synthetics pesticides or added sugar the
only thing in balance of natur's fruit
and veggie capsules are fruits and
veggies right now our listeners can get
35% off their first order and they'll
also get a free fiber and spice
supplement balance of Nature's fiber and
spray supplement is a revolutionary
fiber drink with a unique blend of 12
spices and Whole Foods our producer Mr
Davies over here makes it a point to
bring his balance of nature fruit and
veggie capsules anytime we're on the
road he takes them every day because you
know he's looking a little sickly okay I
said you got to make sure I want to keep
all of the balance of nature to myself
but in my great magnanimity I said Mr
Davies you can have some and he's
looking much better for it as far as I'm
concerned go to balance of nature.com
use promo code NES KW for 35% off your
first order as a preferred customer plus
get a free bottle of fiber and spice
that is balanceof
nature.com promo code nolles
klees for 35% off your first preferred
order plus a free bottle of fiber and
spice turning from a woman I think
justly complaining or understandably
complaining to a woman who is not
understandably complaining we turn now
to Sunny host from The View who insists
that most Americans are
racist there are absolutely racist
people in this country it is not the
vast majority of people in this country
and I feel like FBI director said white
supremacy is the biggest threat to our
country today well that still doesn't
mean that that's the vast majority of
people are I just don't believe that in
my daytoday life that the people that
you're encountering Harbor racist
viewpoints I do think that this division
that we're you look like me you would
believe differ but you know what listen
the woman the woman so but just to just
to understand are we saying do we think
the vast majority of Americans are
racist that's what I'm trying to help me
understand I think that there is a
significant portion um that are racist
and you can't dismiss my lived
experience and I never would I I would
never when I say that there are a lot of
racis in this country I just experienced
my son walking down the beach being
called the
n-word several times in Florida so don't
you can't say I believe that the vast
majority of people aren't racist we
don't know that there are 300 million
people in this country I would never
minimize your lived experience any more
than I would mine as an Arab
woman the majority of Americans are
racist even though there's no um and by
racist of course Sunny hustin does not
mean people attacking whites for the
color of their skin by law by culture no
no no it can't be that because you can't
be racist against white people no no
it's got to be racism against black
people and to a much lesser degree every
other race and this is not borne out by
any statistics this is not borne out by
any particular trends that anyone can
point to so of course Sunny host has to
say well no the proof is my personal
anecdotes and you ought to believe me
though Sunny hustin is not really all
that credible as uh Nick fond dearo
points out as this clip went viral she's
been known to spread the these sorts of
hoaxes before but we hear this kind of
stuff all the time no no no look
whatever the statistics show whatever
you have experienced in your own
personal life just trust us America is
deeply profoundly racist there's no
answer to
it I don't think that line Works quite
as as well anymore I don't but it it is
the
consistent uh cheat of left-wing
Scoundrels it is the once you've run out
of every other argument once you've run
out of every other um tactic in politics
then you just cut to saying well my
opponents are terrible racists and
that's that and if you dare ask me for
evidence oh boy then you're a racist too
how dare you question my lived
experience with these pesky little
things like facts and statistics and uh
history that's always what it will get
to and you're going to hear a lot more
of it in this election cycle because
there's not very much for the Democrats
to brag about the economies and shambles
we on the brink of World War III we
don't have any borders effectively
you've got illegal aliens being let off
the hook for additional crimes that they
commit in this country they've got
nothing and so TR truly the only
argument they're going to have they're
going to try to pretend that the economy
is better than than it is and then after
that they're going to say well you're a
racist aren't you that's that's the
evidence it's prove positive that all
the other issues for the Democrats are
not going very well now speaking of
media
figures there is an undercover
right-wing investigation par
excellance by way of James o'keef
founder of project Veritas who now runs
a new organization called OMG the
O'Keefe Media Group at
James James went on a date apparently
with a top cyber security official at
the White House this is a fella so James
pretended to be a gay guy and he he
interviewed him over dinner and drinks
to figure out if Joe Biden's going to be
the nominee if kamla Harris is going to
be the Vice Presidential nominee and if
Democrats in the White House are excited
about that
Prospect
I work the so so you're you're pretty
high up in the government yeah I'm
fairly high up I'm good at keeping
secrets and so I manage two federal
agencies the state department and USA ID
so when you say SEC it's like security
like you're protecting the networks of
the federal agency you give all your
information to the mission is to protect
information sir we we are like the
president's voice when we go into
meetings in terms of discussing and and
promoting the president's priorities is
he is he going to be the the nominee
yes and she will be the vice president
nominee yeah I don't there was a debate
about removing her from the ticket but
sadly they didn't she can't keep black
stab they quit on her in Mass but with
him I mean I know I know he's got
dementia yeah well he's definitely
slowing down they know that he has those
issues I think so they're shows it and
to it same with Harris she's not popular
but you can't remove the first black
lady to be vice president from the
presidential ticket like what kind of
message are you going to send to like
all the African-American voters how
would you spin that people would be like
what the like she's a woman and
she's multi-racial I think I think that
they're really concerned about but they
won't say it I guess if they say it
publicly is a they can't say it public
no they've got they got to
privately he got him he totally got this
guy the best part of the undercover
investigation of course is that James
O'Keefe's disguise is a pair of glasses
and a somewhat effeminate posture that
that was his whole disguise Clark Kent
he just goes in there so um can you tell
me about how much you all hate Biden and
kamla oh sure random guy I just Matt you
sure seem interested in Joe Biden and
kamla Harris why do you keep looking
over at that cameraman over there anyway
yeah we think Biden's a big dummy and
he's totally demented and Kamala we hate
her and we'd throw her overboard except
she's the first black female vice
president and so we can't throw her
overboard and if we tried to skip over
her replace her with Gavin Newsome or
somebody it would never work because uh
we'd all be called racists just like
Sunny hustin did to everybody on The
View so anyway yeah any other questions
that are extremely sensitive that could
get me in trouble and and make the White
House look bad hey how can be wearing a
name badge that says James o'keef that's
right anyway I don't know th this kind
of a clip is one of the things
that really starts to disprove
conspiracy theories because if this guy
if the top cyber security guy over in
the Biden Administration is this clumsy
as James points out then I don't know
maybe there isn't a super competent evil
cabal who's running any everything and
now the the information that we get here
is not it's not sensitive in the sense
that we all knew this right we all knew
that Joe Biden is scile we all knew that
kamla Harris is one of the
worst politicians ever she's she's
actually good at getting herself into
positions of power but she's really bad
with the public the public doesn't like
her at all she can barely string
together a coherent sentence we all know
the Democrats want to replace not only
by Biden but also kamay Harris and they
can't do it because Kamal Harris is a
black lady and they can't do it because
Biden's going to cling to power we know
it I guess the value in this kind of a
sting is to hear it from the horse's
mouth the value in this kind of Sting is
to living in an age where we are
constantly being gaslit to use the
popular phrase in the age where we are
constantly being lied to and told not to
believe our own Lying Eyes that the
White House thinks this stuff
too and then you get
no less important than the substance of
what this undercover investigation
reveals is the theatrical flare of James
O'Keefe revealing himself so you work in
cyber security for the White House and
my my question is what are you
doing on a
meeting with James o what type of cyber
security operation are you guys running
over we're running a good SEC operation
obviously not obviously not you're
sitting here with me absolutely great
stuff this this is what this is what we
have James oi for is this kind of stuff
uh but it won't it won't matter at all
even though the the Democrats and the
White House officials they all are
seeing the same things we're seeing they
all know the same things that we know
it's not going to change you know there
have been some people suggesting that
there is going to be a uh politician
exmachina comes out of the the wall in
the Final Act of this election season
and it's going to be Nome or it's going
to
be Michelle Obama That's the really
popular one now Michelle Obama is going
to come out of the woodwork at the
convention and she's gonna they're going
to kick out Biden and they're going to
kick out kamla and because Michelle is a
black lady she can replace kamla and
she's going to be the top of the ticket
and she's going to win 57 states and I
just don't buy it it's it's just so
clever it's just so elaborate
it assumes so much it assumes for one
that Michelle Obama even wants to be
president I don't think she really does
I I guess a lot of people would like to
be president but she's said many times I
don't want to do the kind of stuff that
my husband had to go through so she
wouldn't run maybe she would accept it
at the convention but you still have to
go through the the gamut even if you
just accepted it there in in the general
election and then every every minute
you're in office I just don't buy it and
I don't think Biden's going to give it
up I think
this is the race we've got and some
Republicans are unhappy that we've got
Donald Trump as the presumptive nominee
but it should be a consolation to those
Republicans that many many Democrats are
just as unhappy that Joe Biden is at the
top of the
ticket and it's very funny to see James
O'Keefe you know slightly limp his wrist
and put on a pair of glasses and speak
in a you know with a little tiny bit of
a lisp and all of a sudden nobody knows
who he is now speaking of weird sex
stuff there is a shocking new study out
about transgenderism which we'll get to
in one second first though we got to
talk about Renewal by Anderson right now
text nolles to 200 300 if your house is
feeling a little chilly right now you
might want to consider window
replacements I get it for most
homeowners window replacement is not
something they've ever done before might
be a bit of a daunting task well luckily
there is a company that will do the work
for you Renewal by Anderson is your
One-Stop shop for window design menu
manufacturer and installation Windows
play a crucial role in regulating indoor
temperatures if you notice a spike in
your heating or cooling bills it maybe
do to inefficient windows don't put it
off any longer Renewal by Anderson
offers limited fully transferable and
best in the nation warranty coverage
right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free inhome consultation on
quality energy efficient Affordable
Windows or patio doors with special
financing options text nolles K wle to
200 300 for a free consultation you will
save 375 bucks off every window and 775
bucks off every door these savings will
not last long so be sure to check it out
I had a carpenter write to me
unsolicited say that when he works on
homes with Windows from Renewal by
Anderson it's the best DCS I have a
cousin who works for them says they are
fabulous texting privacy policy in terms
and conditions at text plan. us texting
en rolls for recurring automated text
marketing messages messaging data rates
may apply reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointment now.com for full offer
detail s my favorite comment yesterday
is from Cheryl Christensen who says why
is Zuckerberg apologizing to parents Who
provided these phones to their kids but
then didn't use parental controls or
monitor their activity online that's the
parents responsibility I think because
Zuckerberg realized that if he turned to
a bunch of parents who've had children
face tragedies on social media and said
hey screw you I'm not apologizing to you
that would have looked very bad so he
just did what he felt optically he had
to do and politically he had to do and
maybe he felt it was the nice and
sensitive thing to do but I tend to
agree parents should not be giving their
kids
smartphones there and if if you do give
your kid a smartphone for whatever
reason there should be a lot of controls
on it which probably one can get around
anyway
but the the fault for all these terrible
outcomes for young people on social
media does not lie primarily with Mark
Zuckerberg I'm happy to blame Zuckerberg
for a lot of stuff the guy may have
thrown the 2020 election to uh Donald
Trump or to Joe Biden rather by
targeting Donald Trump he did he's done
all sorts of terrible things but I don't
think we can really blame him for
parents giving their kids smartphones
okay turning back to weird sex
[Music]
stuff now speaking of personality
disorders the Harvard Divinity School in
its office of diversity inclusion and
belonging
that's the new version that's the
updated version of Dei diversity equity
and inclusion it's now diversity
inclusion and belonging is
hosting a gathering to breathe and
heal this uh I guess it it took place
yesterday the Gathering to breathe and
heal uh to uh gather to breathe and heal
naturally and to grieve and to share the
heaviness of what we're holding with
other others it's not a space for debate
Harvard is not a space for debate rather
it is a container for holding emotions
in community knowing that the circle
holds us all whether we agree or
disagree we're not going to debate we're
just going to go along with whatever the
libs at the Dei office want and We
Gather we Center anything that has
happened that we need to prioritize and
so what is this all about well this is
to create a space for us to discuss and
process the departure of our former
president Claud Dean gay
the woman who was completely unqualified
to hold her position as the president of
Harvard the woman who had 11 academic
Publications half or more of which she
plagiarized the woman who just even that
poultry number of Publications that's
less than serious people would have in
graduate school forget about an entire
academic career leading up to the top
spot at Harvard a woman who committed
the most egregious academic
crime uh she lost her job oh and also
she seemed to justify genociding the
Jews she lost she lost her job and we
need to grieve and we need to heal about
that why are we grieving why are we
healing is it just because Harvard
Divinity School is completely insane
that's part of it is it just because the
Harvard students and the appara and the
administration are super lib and bizarre
yeah that's part of it at a deeper level
though this is about rewriting the story
of Claudine Gaye firing yeah look Chris
rufo and the conservatives they got that
scalp they got Harvard to fire the
president
but they're going to rehab her they
grudgingly let this President go and the
rewriting I I could see it from day one
is going to be Harvard Brave Harvard
president pushed out by racists because
they have no more arguments so it's
always got to be racism that you saw
this in Claud Dean Gay's resignation
letter
she really did not take responsibility
for all of the perfectly legitimate
reasons she was fired never should have
gotten the job in the first place she
insinuated she stated that it was
because of racism that she was pushed
out of her job that that was scene one
in the rehab story now we're at scene
two which is the Harvard Administration
and the students coming to get to heal
for this awful thing that happened to
the community which is that that nasty
racist conservative Christopher rufo and
his gang of the Klux Clan pushed this
poor baguer scholar out of her job
because of their
hatred and I don't think they're going
to put her back in the position because
she was obviously so terrible at it and
unqualified
but no one will remember the real reason
no no one outside of conservatives
paying attention will ultimately
remember the real reason she was fired
now speaking of people getting fired
remember when was it month month or so
ago we had a an unfortunate video
circulating around Washington DC and
really the whole internet and it was a
congressional staffer engaging in very
very depraved acts in a
senate hearing room and uh so the the
capital police
investigated and they declined to press
charges they declined to press charges
because they said uh that they're not
sure that uh that the video viol any
laws it surely broke the laws the rules
of the Senate and the staffer ended up
leaving his job I assumed he was fired
but now it's actually being reported
that he resigned from his job for for
filming himself doing depraved sexual
acts in the sacred Temple of democracy
that we were sold was so important that
we can't have Midwestern Granny's taking
selfies in it but a homosexual Democrat
staffers in the Senate can film
themselves doing a lot worse than
holding Nancy Pelosi's Lector or
whatever the January sixs were doing
that day well they're not they're not
even going to press charges now it's
fine Move Along Move Along nothing to
see here the the way that they justify
this is they say look he broke the rules
and so he'll be fired but what's the law
that he broke to which I
say if there is no law against bringing
some dude into the Senate and having him
do extremely depraved things to you on
camera and then you know filming it and
then upload it and if there's no law
against
that there should be a law against that
the the Congress needs to stop whatever
it's doing I know they're focused on the
budget or the war in the Middle East or
whatever that can wait take 15 minutes
pass a law that says that you can't turn
the Senate hearing rooms into
particularly extremely depraved gay
brothel and porn sets and then past
that done we should have B we should
have bipartisan consensus we wouldn't
the Democrats would fight it tooth and
nail just like they're fighting
deporting illegal aliens who have DUIs
but I think that would be that'd be a
good law to pass I'm for that government
regulation now something very very
exciting I told you that we were going
to get new Mayflower cigars in I was
hoping by mid-march or so but I didn't
know when they'd go online they've sold
out it was the biggest cigar launch I
think ever in history we had what was
estimated at an aggressive rate by the
top guys in the industry to be a 4mon
supply of Mayflower cigars and we sold
them in 24 hours and then we got another
little extra bit on a shipment that we'
been pre-selling for it sold out
immediately they and I think one last
time sold out immediately and we're not
allowed to pre-sell them too far in
advance well good news for you folks and
I'm telling you right now Michael N show
audience
the they're available for pre-order
they're not going to ship just yet but
they're available now for pre-order this
is a very sizable batch and I'm telling
you it is going to sell out and it's
going to sell out very very fast so if
you want to get your delicious Mayflower
cigars you missed the first time or you
got some but you didn't get enough and
you only got a sampler pack or whatever
order them now order as many as you are
going to want for the foreseeable future
because we can't rush this process this
has already taken us months to get this
Supply it's going to once this sells out
it's going to take us months afterward
21 years old or older to order some
exclusions May apply also it's Groundhog
Day and the groundhog might be surprised
by his shadow but you don't have to be
surprised by yours control your Shadow
this ground toog day with Jeremy's
razors this ground toog day Jeremy's
razors is offering 15% off the founders
kit which can be your choice between the
Precision 5 or smooth six razors the
founders kit is a One-Stop shop for your
shaving needs razor shave cream and post
shave bomb and a nice travel bag so make
sure you go to Jeremy
rers.us a groundhog more than we can
trust scientists to predict the climate
it's nice to have trust in Jeremy's
razors to deliver a great shave every
time finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the
show I was up very late last night I was
in a podcast studio all day yesterday I
did I think nine or 10 hours of shows
for the whatever podcast available now
on my YouTube channel there's one little
debate with some a handful of people on
feminism and then there was the big
whatever dating show which I was on last
year and I I've now made my annual
appearance you can get that on YouTube
and then I woke up this morning and what
got me out of bed after very little
sleep I'll tell you what the mailbag our
mailbag is sponsored by P talk go to P
talk.com nscw for an additional 50% off
your first month take it
away hey Michael big fan of the show
quick question for you what is the most
recent issue you have changed your
stance on and what made you change your
mind great question I would say the
biggest thing I've changed my mind on
recently is xiin Ping of all things I'm
not saying I'm Pro shiin ping or
anything now but I I used to believe
that the Chinese Communist party was
just you know just communist there's
commies nothing really different between
Shan ping and some of his predecessors
in that role and I don't think that's
true actually I think that xiin ping is
not even close to a doctrinaire
communist and that makes him a much more
uh worthy and formidable adversary uh
and the thing that changed my mind on it
was reading some of his speeches because
chairman shei uh speaks in in some ways
like a conservative certainly on some
cultural issues I don't think there's
any risk of wokeness coming to China but
but even on the economy he says yeah we
need liberalized markets and C certain
places but we don't we don't want the
liberalization of the markets to run
away such that the the tail wags the dog
or anything like that but yes we do need
some free markets they can be a
wonderful thing and uh even the way he
describes the ideology I think he says
it's socialism with Chinese
characteristics or something like that
uh so it's not it's just not not quite
as simple and ideological as you would
you would expect from you know reading
in a an elementary textbook about the
Chinese Communist party and we should we
should get wise to that because China is
challenging the United States which is
the global hedgemon for bipolarity and
if if all we continue to do especially
on the right is fight against a
caricature of you know the damn Reds
over there in China uh we're we're not
going to be able to seriously confront
the the real adversary next question hi
Michael my name is Conor Caldwell and me
and my wife are very Avid pasta enjoyers
we use pasta in general as a relatively
simple and easy recipe for the week so
we are not stressing out so much about
dinner and I'm curious uh you being
Italian what is your favorite pasta for
one and then what is your favorite pasta
recipe because those can obviously be
very different um but I'm curious as to
what your favorite pasta SL pasta recipe
is and you know how you prepare it what
do you pair it with whether that's a
wine or some other fun liquid you like
to enjoy um but yeah anyway I appreciate
your answer and looking forward to
hearing back from you thank
you my favorite pasta my favorite dish
My my what I would ask for if I were on
death row and I had my final meal would
be sweet little Alisa's lasaga which
which gets us to a distinction in pasta
between fresh pasta and dry pasta fresh
pasta you roll out and there's a lot of
egg in it dry pasta is what you buy in
the cardboard box so you roll out the
fresh pasta for the lasagna and then you
boil it for a minute or two and you lay
it down in the pot and then you get the
nice delicious uh bolog sauce which uh
Alisa's version is very very good and it
has beef and pork in it and then you get
a little bamal and then you put a little
bit of the cheese the parmesan cheese
and then you layer it again and you
rinse and repeat until you get a nice
juicy delicious lasagna now that's a
little bit labor intensive if uh I want
fresh pasta but I don't want to roll it
out I've been reliably informed by sweet
little Alisa just some days ago that the
fresh pasta from Costco kind of slaps in
her words and uh if I don't even want to
deal with that then I'd probably make
the quickest kind of pasta that I I
would go for on any given day would be
spaghetti alak carbonara which is very
simple it's like an Italian bacon egg
and cheese where you uh fry up a little
ponchetta in a pan you know Alo a little
ponchetta and then you make your pasta
and then you make a sauce that's out of
egg eggs with some extra yolk in there
and a lot of Parmesan cheese and a lot
of pepper people underdo the pepper you
got to put a lot of pepper in there and
then you kind of mix in the egg you're
not frying the egg you just mix it in
with the pasta over very very low heat
and you kind of spin it all around and
then you make a delicious pasta dish
that was probably a more thorough answer
than anyone was anticipating next one
hello Mr nolles my name is Noah and I a
PhD student at the University of
Connecticut studying Neuroscience I'm a
Catholic and have always believe that
God chose to limit his power by giving
us free will however I haven't been
great at articulating this truth how may
I articulate this to people who do not
believe that we have free will I ask
because whenever someone wants me to
explain I get speechless anyway I look
forward to hearing your thoughts thank
you my favorite way of convincing people
that Free Will exists is by just
punching them in the face I just you
know they say like oh Free Will doesn't
exist I just start punching them in the
face you know and then they'll say hey
stop punching me in the face I say I
can't I can't I'm not even punching you
I have no will this was just all
predetermined sorry haha you know give
him a swirly or something no I don't
recommend that I don't recommend any
violence but I would recommend maybe
describing to them that possible
scenario because if there's no free will
then there's no moral culpability at all
and usually when people deny free will
they're doing so because they recognize
rightly that God is Sovereign over the
universe and they're trying to make
sense of how that can be the case that
God is totally Sovereign but also man
has Free Will and how do how do how do
Will and Grace interact and uh one way
to think about it simply is that God is
outside of time and space so you know we
we View events happening within time but
for God it's all the same he's seeing it
all at at uh all the time so the two
don't really contradict each other and
uh while God's grace is um comes from
him obviously we U must have the ability
to turn away from God's grace and to
cooperate with God's grace and so it's
not to say that man is so totally free
that we can do whatever we want
including to save ourselves that's not
it at all but we do have at least the
modum of freedom to cooperate or reject
God's grace
um without without which there would be
no no moral culpability whatsoever and
you can keep punching your friends next
one hello there Puff Daddy uh John here
from Alaska with a philosophy question
brought to your mind by your coverage of
the show about hell on Amazon last week
um so we know angels are great and
powerful and me the spiritual world is
good but we also know that the material
world is good because everything that
God has created is good so how do you
affirm that angels are greater than men
without positing that the material world
is evil
evil and in other news uh in light of
recent polling data and bearing in mind
that he needs to shore up the Suburban
white women vote uh do you think Donald
Trump might tap Taylor Swift to be his
VP uh what do you think uh thank you
bye-bye sign me up Trump Swift 2024
would be unstoppable I'm skeptical it
would happen but it would be unstoppable
as for the uh first
question uh as to the first part of your
question uh you you're right that
the god makes the spiritual World good
and God makes the physical world good as
well some of the Gnostic heresies have
denied the goodness of the physical
World perhaps most famously the cathar
heresy the albigensian heresy uh was one
that cropped up that the church had to
put down because it would have destroyed
all of civilization and it said that the
material world is very very bad and so
it encouraged well basically the end of
of our material existence but no the
material world is good too you know sin
and death pervade the world as a
consequence of the fall of Man and so
that leads to corruption all over the
place but uh it doesn't mean that you
know we just give up on it entirely I
the I think the mistake you make there
is you say we know that the angels are
greater than humans but they're not
actually they are in I guess in the the
order of creation but uh what so amazing
is that our Lord himself takes on flesh
and and becomes man so he in his
Incarnation elevates mankind which is
made lower is made corporeal but
elevates the flesh up to to become as
sons of God uh and this would arouse the
enmity of a certain uh once beautiful
angel now uh rotting in a pit of fire
forever and uh and it's it in Nobles
mankind you know um
so it yes it's true the angels are pure
spirit and we are not pure Spirit we're
spirit and flesh together um
but we we have we have been um raised up
with our Lord who who lowers himself to
take on flesh and dwell Among Us okay uh
let's get to some written mail bag
before we go from Colby Dear Mr nolles
do you believe therapy is worthless and
doesn't benefit Society outside of
enabling people I'm in therapy right now
and trying to use it to get over some
issues I've been tamping down I don't
like therapy but I need to talk to
someone because suffering in silence
isn't helping me out if anything I'm
seeing it as limiting my growth as a
person and I'm not achieving my full
potential with whatever time I've left
on Earth so is suffering in silence your
only view when it comes to therapy
psychology or anything else of that
nature I'd love to hear your stance on
this and hope it'll help me with how I
should deal with therapy and my own
mental health going forward oh no I hope
I haven't given that impression I think
when I I say suffer in silence uh well
the other day I was using it in
reference to Elmo because Elmo tweeted
out said how is everybody doing okay I
got to figure out my Elmo impression and
everyone just started whining and
complaining and I said hey stop whining
and complaining you know like keep it to
yourself and keep a stiff upper lip and
I do think that therapy is
overprescribed even talk therapy but
especially psychiatric uh counseling
where the basically the shrinks are just
drug dealers and people go to their
shrink for 30 years and they never get
any better they usually get worse and
then maybe they just get some drugs on
top of that that's that's really bad and
I'm I oppose it furthermore I oppose
pathologizing ordinary aspects of The
Human Condition um which we tend to do
these days but that doesn't mean that
all therapy is bad I think that some
therapy can be very very good I know
some conservatives write it off but I
don't just totally write it off in fact
Drew claven once said that he was cured
by therapy and he said he might be the
only person ever in history that's been
cured by therapy but it can happen so I
I don't discourage you at all from going
to a therapist I would just make sure
one that your therapist is on the same
page with you about fundamental things
you know if your therapist is a big lib
atheist and disagrees on qu basic
questions about what man is what man's
role is in the world what happiness and
flourishing are then the therapy is
probably not going to be very helpful uh
but if the shrink is on the right page
and and there is a path to getting
better and to not needing the shrink
anymore then I think that can be very
helpful okay that's our show now there
will be a member block even though I
will be flying back to Tennessee shortly
after this you will get a sneak peek of
me getting a sneak peek of an amazing
rap video the greatest rap video that
has come out in the last month without
question by a member of
the and it's a wrap video about
Mayflower cigars which are back in stock
and you can pre-order right now and
should pre-order if you ever want to get
them in the next few months 21 years old
or older to purchase some exclusions
apply check it out over there then I
will see you back in the studio chair
next
[Music]
week